[Music]
um our first speaker is
ian little please join me in welcoming
him
oh thank you everyone uh thank you for
eat uh i'm
i'm super glad to be here and i as you
can see i work for schneider electric
and i'm grateful for
for their support not only in the work
that we do uh but uh
uh sending me to a wonderful conference
like this
so i'll be talking about how uh with a
small team within schneider
uh we use r to design visualizations
that hopefully
uh can benefit the entire company and
more importantly our customers
so you might ask who are schneider
electric where are more than 150 000
employees worldwide and our basic
mission statement is to help our
customers use
electricity safely and efficiently
so you might wonder how do we use our
data
our products collect and transmit data
on things like
power consumption number of operations
room temperature and our customers have
questions
like when am i going to need to replace
this power supply uh
and how much uh how much energy did my
facility how much should have used last
month
or do i have enough cooling in my data
center so these are sort of the some of
the fundamental questions that our
customers are
are interested in answering
and schneider being a very large company
has a a lot of different business units
and business units will each have their
own ways
of of reaching their customers to to
look at their data
and that our businesses use different
visualization tool sets
and among these are you know things like
chart js
d3 qlik sense these all run in the
browser and they use
javascript but perhaps importantly for
for me
none of these is ggplot2
so a little bit on how we are organized
or how uh
what my perspective on the company is
that each schneider electric business
they each have data science teams and we
also have a central data science team
uh that focuses on questions that can
sort of help all the other data science
teams and this is
this is who i work with and whenever i
talk to somebody who works in data
science
and and they tell me what they're
working on i find
this uh this model that you know from uh
from hadley wickham and garrett groman
to be tremendously useful i'm i'm sure
most all of you are familiar with us as
well uh that the
we have these fundamental steps and as
as someone describes
what they do i i sort of slot this away
into into which steps
uh they're working on so i'll i'll do
this for uh for you as well
uh the very the
the great majority of the team that i
work on uh
work on the sort of the import tidy
transform
and model steps of uh of the data
science process and it's a larger team
based principally in france they use
almost exclusively python and their
mission
is to deploy models and data as
as web services and we're trying to get
into the uh
sort of into the developer space so if
uh
if there's something you're interested
in this is a sort of a new initiative
from schneider called exchange
and you're very welcome to uh to check
it out
uh when we uh deploy our models
interestingly enough we uh
we do this using azure ml and and right
now
uh david smith is uh in a
simultaneous talk he's he's talking
about azure ml so if you get a chance to
uh
to watch that on video that that may be
interesting
so the part of the team that i work with
is concentrates more on visualize and
communicate
we're a smaller team we use r
and the thing that we deploy is
practices
and here we are uh here's me and we are
very fortunate to be working with a phd
student
at uh at iowa state uh haley jepson
and last year we got a challenge from
the schneider electric ui design team
the they're responsible for setting ui
design standards across all of these
different
uh customer facing tools and uh they
wanted us to help contribute to
data visualization guidelines for for
these customer facing tools and
uh after this meeting i was i was
super excited and then i started looking
at it
and thinking and this is what started to
appear
data visualization guidelines for entire
schneider electric customer facing tools
and it
it became a very intimidating problem
and uh thought about it for a while and
figured
what we need are some tools and so i'd
like to spend the next few minutes
talking about some of the uh specific
members in the community
who have sort of inspired us to to help
point us the way
um i feel bad that i'm singling out four
because
it's uh that number of folks who have
who have helped me and helped us
is of course much greater than four so i
hope you'll all forgive me if
if i focus on four the first is klaus
wilkie
uh many people here may be familiar with
his uh
his book uh fundamentals of data
visualization
and he offers some very solid advice
and as as as you may know he uses ggpot2
to create everything in the book but the
book itself
doesn't contain any code and and this is
this is brilliant
and so from klaus we want to sort of
take inspiration of technique
and you know if i'm being a little bit
too honest
that if i if we just took copies of this
book and distributed them throughout
schneider
that's going to get us a lot of the way
there in coming up with uh data
visualization guidelines so
what we hope to do is to maybe uh tweak
uh some of klaus's advice and adapt it
to schneider contacts
the next inspiration uh you're you're
all very familiar with the
uh with jenny's keynote this morning um
and from her uh i'm very inspired by the
the tooling and we got a little bit of
this
this morning is that she's very good at
pointing out how we need to focus
on what's important and to work towards
good enough and
i very much like this image this is from
a tweet that
that she sent out in conjunction with a
paper good enough practices in data
science
with greg wilson and others and
what makes uh what makes this idea so
interesting
is that she helps provide the tools
to help us focus our ideas and uh you
may be familiar with the use this
package
i use it extensively and then the happy
get with
r and i think one of the best urls
best url names ever what they forgot to
teach you about our stats
the third inspiration as uh if you were
here last year for david robinson's
keynote uh this this helped to clarify a
lot of things for me
is that i i i suppose i was a lot like
dave
in that i thought that that things would
become
less useful to uh more useful as the
idea became more mature
but in practice anything that is still
on your computer
is essentially useless and anything that
is off your computer
has got a chance and so this uh
this was a uh a very
uh clarifying idea from dave that that
i'm going to try to carry through
and then finally community
and that our ladies has been a great
inspiration in how to really set up an
effective community
uh i i hope it's okay that i i uh single
out uh
gabrielle in this uh perhaps appropriate
because we're in san francisco where she
launched it and now as as i'm sure you
know
hundreds of chapters and in addition to
uh to the great technical exchanges that
uh that go on
uh what benefits me and certainly i'm
not central to this
is that um
through their amplification of voices
and focusing on some very important
conversations
it really benefits all of us so uh i
wanted to uh
uh to point out our ladies as a is a
particular inspiration to me
so i'd like to spend the next few
minutes going through a uh
a particular problem that we've uh that
we're addressing at schneider and this
is to come up with a categorical color
palette
and the challenge is that we have these
brand colors that are optimized for
marketing
but they're not optimized for data
visualization and there's as
as you may know that there's these are
two competing sets of
there's uh two competing sets of goals
here
and from the data visualization point of
view we want to propose a related
categorical palette
and i want to take into account color
vision deficiency
yet still remain snidery
and of course schneidery is in the eye
of the beholder
and particularly the ui design team who
will have the uh
the ultimate say on this
so i'm going to walk you through what uh
some of the steps that we went through
is we start
out with technique and as i say the the
book offers some useful advice
and klaus is also one of the
contributors to the uh the color space
package
and if you go on youtube and look uh for
the user talks last year
uh that uh akam silas uh
had a tremendously useful talk that uh
uh that really helped us get on our way
and as a bit of a side note it was at
this conference a year ago that i was uh
very fortunate to be sitting beside
during a session uh carlos scheidegger
who's who's here this time as well and
during the the wee break breaks between
the presentations i got
a very short course on color theory that
was very illuminating but the upshot of
it here
is and will chase talked about this a
little bit this morning i'll use
slightly different words
is to think in terms of hue chroma
and luminance rather than red green and
blue
and there's all these interesting paths
that you can go down
uh you know for instance we start with
rgb hue
chroma luminance visible gamut color
vision deficiency perceptual distance
it just goes on and on and each of these
are super interesting rabbit holes that
that haley and i we found ourselves lost
in them
um and it makes for great fun and
and at times i you know i think we felt
like this guy
so what we needed is focus and this is
where we uh
uh we come back to uh the this idea of
tooling
and that we needed numbers to show uh
perceptual differences
and that we we began with the color
space package and then we're uh
we're tuned in to thomas lynn peterson's
farber package which uh
which can be used to to quantify
differences between colors
and we decided to try to put these
together with a set of tools that we
could use
and this is available out on github it's
called palavel and it's this
uh this first sort of mix between color
space and farber
and in the in the spirit of the uh the
faa
certified duct tape that we see here
it's it's good enough now
i i hope to improve it later uh but
it it it got us through what we needed
to do it's 70
there
then on to communication uh we created
an internal blog
and then using distill and we we're
lucky enough at uh at
schneider electric that we have a uh an
internal instance of github enterprise
so a lot
of these uh this great tooling uh that
the tidyverse team have
built for open source that we can adapt
uh within the company
uh so we're able to serve this out on
github enterprise it's a
distilled blog another package from our
studio and it helps us to get our ideas
out there
and then finally once we get the ideas
out there we need to seek more opinions
and we need to get new perspectives so
we're building this thing at schneider
electric our term of art a schneider
electric is a community at work
and the idea is we wanted to be by
practitioners for practitioners that if
you know we don't care what tool you use
we know that we're going to be using all
different tools
but if we can meet and discuss what we
think about when we when we create a
visualization
uh this can be a useful thing
and we also hope that this can be a
useful point of contact with the ui
design team so if we come up with
recommendations that we hope that
all of these different business units
can use that at least we've had a chance
to discuss them amongst ourselves
and you know first of all we'll get
we'll get better ideas
and hopefully this this helps to
facilitate
uh adoption of the ideas
so our result is uh this is our first
proposal here
um and this uh takes into account uh
color vision deficiency it's potentially
schneidery
and we've had some useful feedback and
i'll share some of it with you as i
think we'll
i'm not sure how well it's showing up in
this on these screens but
we may in fact remove the reds uh
because for for some colored vision
deficient folks it was difficult to tell
apart from the purples
and uh as i'm learning that that red can
be a very useful color but can sometimes
convey a sentiment that you're not
intending to convey
and with a categorical color palette
unless you want to say that something
is really requires your attention
uh we might go with something that's
more neutral
but the thing here is that we designed
this using
r but the thing that we deliver are the
hex codes
and that the rest of schneider as long
as it works
perhaps aren't terribly concerned that
that we used r
uh but that uh that what we do deliver
that these hex codes can be useful
in all of these different tools that uh
that then get uh
used in front of the customers
so i'd like to spend a uh just to sort
of wrap up with the uh
with some ideas of other things that i
was thinking to put in this talk but
didn't make it into the talk so i call
it more broadly
is that under technique i'm very much
like this idea of the grammar of
graphics
as a description as well as a tool
and it's got this very handy
implementation that will build your
chart for you
but it uh for me it helps to focus my
thinking
and to it helps me to be able to
describe in very clear terms to somebody
who's using their own tool
map this variable to the x-axis map this
variable
to to your fill color so on and so forth
uh use this type of scale
and uh
this is just another way that klaus's
book has been tremendously useful uh to
us
in terms of tooling uh interactivity is
something that we're interested in
and uh certainly in front of our
customer that we're using interactive
tools
and uh we're very interested in uh vega
light
and indeed right now uh there's a talk
by alicia shep
who's doing some super cool stuff to
build vega light specs so
please uh make sure you get a chance to
uh to watch that
uh when the videos are released as well
as
dewey dunnington who's talking about
ggplot2 so i
i really wish i could have been in four
places at once right now
perhaps three places at once uh
uh but we uh alicia and i are
we have an organization on github on
vega widget which
provides some tools if you're interested
in vegalite and interactive
visualization
some first steps towards that
with uh with communication just to
reiterate
move things off of your computer get
them into the world so nothing nothing
terribly new there
uh but this one is uh i think this is my
secret uh
uh this has been the secret to a lot of
my success and enjoyment of my job over
the past
six or seven years is to get to know a
local university i am tremendously lucky
that uh that i work in iowa
and uh i'm able to visit iowa state uh
every so often and work with uh heike
hoffman
and this has led us to uh to hire uh uh
some interns uh one of whom is
is here i'm very glad to see her
and uh and uh as well that led to uh
being able to sponsor haley as a phd
student
so if you have a chance to get to know a
local university maybe you run into
uh somebody here uh i find that this is
a
way to sort of continue the spirit of
this conference sort of throughout the
rest of the year
uh so with that i'm happy to yield back
the floor to farid thank you very much
some links that
may be useful and thank you very much
so we have a couple of minutes for
questions let me just check our slido
and if you haven't submitted
you are welcome to stand up and ask a
question as well
um one question is uh it sounds like the
the our team ended up leading the charge
for something that is
going to benefit the entire organization
a huge organization
why do you think your team ended up with
this
opportunity slash responsibility and
what what do you think made you
successful in the end
oh well the the the
i think we we're we're in the right
place we're a central organization
and uh because each business
is is quite rightly interested in their
success
and the success of their customers one
of our charters as a
as a group is to try to get all the uh
to address the interests that are common
to all the businesses
uh so i think we're we're in a good
position to do that um
and uh this this has been a first step
uh
i hope to uh report back at some point
and uh with
all of the other uh uh recommendations
that we'll have made
uh but uh a lot of the a lot of the time
that we had spent last year was really
getting
getting our ducks in her own thinking
about things like communication and
community and
and essentially the sort of the four
points that i i brought up through the
uh
through the slides great great any other
questions off the floor
all right let's thank ian thank you so
much thank you really appreciate it